Big Brother Biden is going after Elon
Musk the Democrat boss over at the
Federal Trade Commission demanding
Twitter identify all journalists who had
access to those explosive Twitter files
that exposed social media censorship as
well as getting their grubby little
hands on internal Communications related
to musk as they probe his takeover of
the company they also want to know why
former Comey Lackey James Baker got
fired from the social media giant the
billionaire calls it a shameful case of
weaponization
and the left-wing journalist who posted
the first batch of Twitter files calls
it an insane overreach so Dana who knew
the FTC was even doing anything these
days they were asleep at this at the
wheel for Minnie Madoff after all that
money went missing but they're going
after Elon they'll do anything to help
protect the left and that's one of the
concerns when Lena Khan got the nod or
the confirmation to be over at the FTC
one of the things that happens here is
first of all the FTC is why is it any of
your business what Elon Musk who owns
his company it's now a private company
but he what he does with his company
that's literally none of their business
what are they alleging well I don't know
I think that they want to know they're
they probably are figuring out why am I
defending her
um
for people whose emails were released
maybe without their consent right and
that's so there was a breach of trust
there and was that was that against the
rules of the FTC but remember that
Republicans can often say mean things
about people in the media okay but the
left will often use the government
against the media where did we see that
during the Barack Obama administration
if you recall remember some reporters
got their phones tapped and things like
that things the the left will always go
after the media from that side of things
when Republicans get mad because they
just want fairness we just want to be
fair should the Republicans not be so
fair and then next time they get in
charge weaponize the government against
the left judge I don't think they should
weaponize the government against the
left I think they should prosecute the
criminals in government who are
violating the law and the reason the FTC
is involved is allegedly they say that
we are protecting consumers you know
from from other people coming in like
the Twitter files and finding out out
who said what at what time and so
basically they're saying protecting
consumers is what the FTC does now this
Lena Khan that Dana talked about is
someone who uh is who's gotten low marks
apparently historically low marks by
people in the FDC for honesty and
integrity she over uh rise staff
recommendations she doubles down on
losing legal strategies that earn her
one courtroom rebuke after another so
you know I don't know why she was chosen
I'm not even going to go there here's
the bottom line Twitter is a private
company the FTC wants to know why James
Baker was fired why because he was with
the FBI you want to keep the FBI in
there so they can call and make sure
that you monitor what's going on and the
other thing is the the other excuse
they're using is they're saying look
there was a consent decree before Elon
Musk even bought Twitter and we got to
make sure that that you know the company
has the ability to comply with 150
million dollar settlement so musk says
what are you talking about they were
going bankrupt now I've got the company
and I'm taking it I'm taking it green
again but this is classic left ideology
go after them trash the First Amendment
it doesn't matter and it's shocking and
embarrassing to anyone who's a First
Amendment attorney that they dare do
this shouldn't the body Administration
kiss the ground Elon walks on because of
all he's doing with Green Tech I don't
know I don't know about that but I I as
a journalist for over half a century can
say with definitively that government
and journalism are different there
should be a wall between the two don't
come looking for the reporter's name
that's the laziest way to investigate
anything you know you just got to let
you know that's how you be is is
absolutely correct why are they why did
they need this information why what's
what exactly is the goal of this of this
probe you know really what what is the
what's the end result of this that they
find out what that Matt taibi had lunch
with Elon Musk I mean it's it's
Preposterous it's overreach and I I get
the creeps when I hear about it and if
someone's emails are out there and they
don't even work for the company anymore
and Elon owns the company why can't he
give those emails to a journalist yeah
well it was fantastic what he did with
the Twitter files most of the mainstream
media yawned and ignored it and acted
like it was nothing and then they always
come back to well it's a private company
they can do what they want but I don't
have a problem with the private company
the fact is they were on conference call
with the government every morning and
they were making decisions uh based on
what the Biden Administration told them
to do and not old Twitter that is
Twitter the old Twitter that's right
it's not government property anymore
yeah and I just think I mean musk is a
riot this guy is hilarious he is there's
no upside to what he's doing I mean he
spent Untold billions on this company
and it the he's her he's kind of hurt
his own brand with the lefties who liked
him for his electric vehicles but he
doesn't care that that's a guy who
actually cares about free speech so I
think he's fantastic he overpaid for the
truth yeah exactly we're happy he
overpaid all right hi winner Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now